[Musique]
bonjour nouveau numéro de pourvu que ça
dure les missions qui rend les
co-responsables sur public sénat
aujourd'hui on vous parle d'immobilier
durable car le bâtiment est aujourd'hui
l'un des secteurs les plus polluants
mais la donne est en train de changer
avec une réglementation plus
contraignante c'est le cas dans
l'immobilier ancien vous verrez que
législateur a choisi de faire la guerre
aux passoires thermiques le marché du
neuf qui est également en train de faire
sa révolution verte on en parlera avec
véronique b d'agde la dg de nexity enfin
construction en bois terre crue ou
encore impression 3d vous verrez que la
technologie ne manquent pas pour
répondre à ces nouveaux enjeux
environnementaux
mais d'abord tout ce qu'il faut savoir
sur l'empreinte carbone du secteur du
bâtiment moins d'une minute c'est parti
quel est l'impact écologique de
l'immobilier
considérable en france l'habitat est
responsable de 25 % des émissions de co2
et même de 40 % si on prend en compte la
phase de construction et les matériaux
au total 4,8 millions de logements sont
considérés comme des passoires
thermiques ils consomment de l'énergie
de manière excessive à cause de leur
toiture ou de leurs fenêtres mal isolée
par exemple
résultat ils font flamber la facture
énergétique des ménages mais alors que
fait l'exécutif jusqu'à présent les
forts été porté sur le neuf entre 1990
et 2015 les émissions de co2 ont baissé
de 4% mais avec les nouvelles règles
européennes
les états devront réduire leurs
émissions de 40 9% à l'horizon 2030 côté
anciens c'est surtout depuis 2022 que le
gouvernement a décidé d'agir et de faire
la guerre aux passoires énergétiques et
les français ils se sentent concernés
l'immobilier durable est aujourd'hui une
priorité 75 % veulent habiter un
logement respectueux de l'environnement
et 59 % sont prêts à réaliser des
travaux de rénovation pour y parvenir
ma vie zoo les énergivores gros
émetteurs de co2 la chasse aux passoire
thermique est bel et bien lancée bonjour
carlington merci d'être avec nous
juristes et experts en immobilier
comment on arrive déjà ce chiffre de 5
millions de passoires thermiques en
france parce que c'est le chiffre qui
est avancé pour le coup par l'état mais
quand on écoute beaucoup d'experts on a
parfois le chiffre de 6,7 millions de
passoires thermiques en france alors là
actuellement en fait il ya eu une petite
chose qu'on a oublié en même temps que
la joie climat c'est le changement du
dpe et le changement
est en fait cette modification qui
soi-disant le rend plus sûrs change en
fait des critères et ce changement de
critères ça joue sur les chiffres donc
on m'a alors on se rapprocherait plus
des 7 millions mais la problématique
c'est qu'il faudrait faire faire un dpe
à toutes les maisons tous les appart et
ça c'est encore pas fait qu'elle ait
définition concrètement d'une passoire
thermique alors c'est un logement
énergivore mais pas que parce que on
oublie aussi que c'est un logement qui
est polluant en émissions de co2 donc un
logement qui est une passoire thermique
il a la note c'est sa f ou g c'est ça
alors oui aujourd'hui c'est ça c'est f
ou g et demain donc 2025 ce sera aussi
eu voilà et si on est chauffé au fioul
par exemple qu'on soit d'ailleurs dans
un logement collectif eau ou en maison
individuelle est ce qu'on est
nécessairement considéré pour le coup
comme une passoire énergétique alors pas
vraiment énergétique mais on est plutôt
polluants en fait parce qu'on a des
maisons neuves qui sont chauffées au
fioul
mais par contre derrière est comme ils
ont une chaudière plus le fuel pas bon
et bien elles sont polluantes voilà
après donc il ya les nouvelles
réglementations qui ont été votées
récemment et là on vit avec cette loi
climat et résidences que peut-être les
jours des passoires thermiques sans
compter on passe te dire ou pas en
france alors
que c'est une tendance parce que
aujourd'hui ce qui est sur la sellette
c'est les locations et les ventes parce
que tous les propriétaires qui vendent
pas ou qui ne nous pas en fait ils sont
pas concernés par la loi climat pour le
moment parce que le gouvernement donc a
décidé d'interdire à la location les
logements donc énergivores e f et g dès
2025 pour les logements j'ai hélas on
dit que c'est dans trois ans quoi
effectivement ça change la donne rome
alors ça change la vie aujourd'hui
pouvait pas mettre en location il faut
que ça change la donne parce que enfin
oui et non parce que ben quand on a bien
envie de faire des travaux bien on va ça
va être le moment de le faire donc on va
se lancer après quand on n'avait pas les
moyens de faire des travaux ça va être
compliqué ouais parce qu'il faut
reconnaître que sortir un logement de
l'état de passoires thermiques et basse
à un coût certain dit entre 40000 60000
euros et il faut il ya une aide publique
mesquida publique telle qu'elle existe
aujourd'hui sera notamment un prix mises
en oeuvre est ce qu'elle est suffisante
alors l aide on fait quand même partie
des pays où on aide le plus par contre
quand on n'a pas les moyens de faire des
travaux et souvent on achète un bien
qu'ils avaient une mauvaise note parce
qu'on n'avait que les moyens d'acheter
ce type de bien là eh ben on n'a pas
plus les moyens de faire les travaux
derrière et qu'on ait une prime ou pas
ah c'est toujours très compliqué même si
les français quand on regarde les
chiffres carlington rénove de plus en
plus leur logement 750 mille logements
rénovés l'an dernier c'est du jamais vu
et donc on se dit que pour le coup les
aides à la rénovation ces 2 milliard
d'euros qu'est ce que ça coûte budget de
l'état pour l'imprimerie nov c'est
peut-être en train de changer un petit
peu les mentalités alors l'idée elle est
vraiment là elle les deux changé les
mentalités elle est surtout de faire
rénover
mieux en fait et est d'inciter les gens
à ne pas faire j'allais dire de bric et
de broc de vraiment faire une rénovation
qui tient la route et qui écologiquement
et positive qui tient la route qui coûte
cher ah oui on peut très bien aussi
faire des travaux de rénovation est
malgré tout resté classé f ou g malgré
les travaux qu'on a fait alors tout
dépend ce qu'on fait comme travaux parce
que sont les principaux faits pour être
sûrs d'eux pour sortir de cet état de
passoires thermiques pour faire
absolument alors les principaux ça va
toujours touchés l'isolation les
ouvrants et puis notre ouïe
porte-fenêtre bardon et et puis
également les chaudières et on oublie un
petit peu c'est la ventilation un bm
c'est parce que plus un r et u minh plus
les difficiles à chauffer et il ya
beaucoup de logements qui sont mal
ventilée et donc du coup ça pose une
problématique de chauffage et derrière
ce sont des nouveaux logements qui sont
énergivores donc plusieurs dizaines de
milliers d'euros pour faire sortir un
engagement de l'état de passoires
thermiques à ça bon après on dit que
enfin en temps on n'entend que de
beaucoup de propriétaires de passoires
thermiques j'entends préfèrent vendre
leur logement plutôt que de les rénover
il ya une vraie tendance là dessus aussi
parce que alors demain en fait emprunté
en 2025 enfin même la
2022 1er septembre 2022 en fait on va
avoir au moment de la vente qu'on
appelle un audit énergétique et cet
audit énergétique va faire une enveloppe
travaux qui va porter en fait j'allais
dire qui va peser sur la valeur du bien
et donc derrière c'est vrai que les gens
craignent ce qui n'est pas tout à fait
vrai en fait ils sont en confiance ceux
qui préfèrent plutôt vendre que de faire
ces travaux de rénovation bah oui des
fois ils ont plutôt tort parce que en
fait ils ont plus intérêt à faire ces
travaux et à continuer donc de tirer
parti de leur bien que de vendre et de
racheter parce qu'on va avoir au bout
d'un moment de moins en moins en fait
de biens qui sont classés ab est de plus
en plus de bien classés fg donc c'est
dire qu'à une décote aujourd'hui sur les
prix des logements qui sont fg notamment
j'ai passoires thermiques par rapport à
un visa qui serait performant j'en veux
dire énergétiquement alors décote une
décote oui plutôt de décote je préfère
parler d' enveloppe travaux parce que
bon souvent on met un chiffre un
pourcentage est la difficulté avec un
pourcentage c'est que derrière pour
chaque logement on est sur des travaux
différents et puis ça va dépendre aussi
de la pression foncière donc en fait on
va pas avoir le j'allais dire le même la
même problématique pour deux logements
différents voilà et donc effectivement
il faut prévoir une enveloppe travaux et
certains estiment que chaque classe fait
baisser en gros 2 5 % le prix d'un
logement quand on descend en dfg c'est
vrai j'ai toujours du mal avec ce
chiffre-là c'est j'allais dire c'est une
moyenne et dès l'instant que c'est une
moyenne en fait il ya des ya des cas où
ça ne sera pas ce sera pas vrai
notamment quand on habite dans le nord
de la france et quand on habite dans le
sud de la france en fait on n'aura pas
le même impact sur le prix et donc un
logement qui est performant
énergétiquement contrario il va se
vendre au mieux plus vite
tout entendu des finances des gens en
tout cas il ya cette loi encore une fois
il ya l'idée que les passoires
thermiques aujourd'hui sont dans le
viseur des autorités c'est ça oui c'est
exactement ça en fait est là c'est
vraiment la loi qui va accélérer la
lutte contre contre la consommation
énergétique puisque on est quand même
sur 45 % de concept de consommation
énergétique dans le logement et puis la
pollution par le dégagement de co2 1
bâtiment
c'est un quart des dégagements donc ça
dans mon sens oui c'est tant mieux merci
beaucoup carlington que juriste et
expert en immobilier alors de nouvelles
contraintes dans l'ancien on l'a vu mais
également de nouvelles normes
environnementales pour les logements
neufs vous allez voir
et oui l'objectif c'est d'obliger les
promoteurs à construire des bâtiments
plus vert bonjour vernis bédague
aujourd'hui giacobbi être l'installer
vous dis actionnera de nexity ce qu'on
appelle la r eu 20/20 cette nouvelle
norme environnementale qui s'applique
depuis le 1er janvier l'ambition l'a
bien compris en creux c'est de faire
chuter les émissions de co2 des
bâtiments rappelle le bâtiment c'est un
quart des émissions de gaz à effet de
serre en france on se dit mais les
logements neufs actuelle il n'était pas
assez suffisant d'un point de vue
énergétique pas assez performante pour
aller fallait aller encore plus loin à
l'évidence il faut aller encore plus
loin puisqu'il ya une nouvelle
réglementation qui s'applique à partir
de cette année elle est très ambitieuse
il faudrait réduire nos et nos gaz à
effet de serre d'à peu près 30% d'ici
2030 2030 c'est demain être complètement
neutre en 2050
cette réglementation mais je pense que
pour nous elle est une chance en réalité
parce qu'elle nous donne un guide on
sait sur quoi on joue alors on doit
jouer à la fois sur les émissions
carbone et sur l'énergie et donc je
pense que pour tous les promoteurs au
fond c'est le but à atteindre et c'est
ce sur quoi nous sommes tous au fond
complètement concentré dans le moment
performant mais plus coûteux cette
nouvelle réglementation certains disent
que ça pourrait faire grimper certains
experts 10 5% sur le coup la
construction des appartements neufs
cette année plus encore pour les maisons
confirme pas ce chiffre et j'ai
l'impression moi je ne sait pas encore
de combien parce qu'il ya beaucoup
d'augmentation vous savez sur le
logement il ya les produits qu'on met
finalement dans le logement il ya les
normes il ya effectivement là et revin
moi je pense que notre objectif à nous
mais vraiment c'est de rendre ce bas
carbone abordable c'est ça qu'on tente
de faire chez nexity et ça ça c'est pas
un oxymore que c'est un non je ne pense
pas non mais je pense que c'est
volontariste en réalité donc ça suppose
de travailler évidemment sur sur les
matériaux on parle du bois porte de
montreuil nous on essaye le bois on
essaie la brique crue on essaye le on
essaye la pierre on
réutilise aussi au fonds d'aidé des
matériaux existants sur une partie de ce
qu'on a construit il y aura sur coup à
court terme après effectivement il y
aura des effets d'échelle et des
synergies mais après il ya un surcoût
qui les liait ce surcoût vers encore une
fois deux je pense que ça dépend comment
on prend les choses je pense qu'il faut
vraiment revoir les modes constructifs
et de nouveau chez nexity on s'y prépare
depuis un moment il faut alléger il faut
simplifier il faut vraiment regarder ce
qui est absolument nécessaire émettre
plus de productivité aussi parce que
plus de productivité chantier et puis
acceptée vous l'avez vous même dit tout
à l'heure plus de rupture d'où par
exemple on travaille sur un bâtiment qui
existent et qui fonctionne je le dis ça
fonctionne en autriche ça fonctionne en
suisse on appelle ça le bâtiment est
essentielle c'est vraiment comme son nom
l'indiqué c'est un bâtiment sans
chauffage éclat sans climatisation ou
son chantage de 100 pays bien sûr alors
c'est un mélange au fond de mode
constructif très traditionnelle des murs
assez épais une vraie circulation d'air
mais léa au meilleur de ce qu'on sait en
physique et en digital aujourd'hui ces
terres que grosso modo la température
intérieure du bâtiment se réguler en
fonction évidemment de la température
extérieure de la de l'isolation et donc
de l'inertie du bâtiment de la
circulation de l'air de la présence
d'humains dans le bâtiment enfin voilà
donc c'est vraiment ça que nous pousse
aujourd'hui dont vous avez dit roupillon
oui mais à court terme insiste beaucoup
disent que construire vert sera plus
chère avec l'idée que qui payent
l'addition à ce que ce taux client paie
l'addition s'il ya son corps une fois
ces hausses de coûts et s'il est ce
qu'il en a les moyens et ce que le
risque justement au contraire c'est
d'avoir des logements durables qu'ils
soient réservés à une élite le contraire
de ce que vous souhaitez ça je pense que
c'est vraiment c'est un risque c'est
vraiment au coeur je pense des tensions
qui existent dans nos entreprises
aujourd'hui nous vous savez nexity
milite ça c'était le combat historique
d'alain dinin pour le logement abordable
et donc effectivement il faut que le
logement vert ne soit pas un logement
réservé à une élite parce que on a
laissé les coudées river mais si moi je
pense que si on fait les bâtiments tels
qu'ils existent aujourd'hui et qu'on
tente de les rendre plus durable là
effectivement les couvents froidement
augmenté il faut repartir sur les modes
constructifs après c'est vrai que tout
pousse aujourd'hui les prix des mobilier
neuf à la hausse on peut revenir aux
fondamentaux le déséquilibre
nick endémique en france entre l'offre
et la demande de logements la
réglementation environnementale ça on
l'a évoqué les pénuries les flambées de
deux matériaux c'est sur une réalité
les prix du foncier ou six ans pour en
parler sur la saison ouais on peut on se
dit voilà les hausses de prix des
logements cette hausse elle est quasi
certaine pendant futur faut pas trop se
leurrer non plus nous on regarde
aujourd'hui avec beaucoup d'intérêt le
débat qui assure le pouvoir d'achat oui
puisque c'est extrêmement liés puisque
les postes 2 et le premier poste des
dépenses des français alors souvent on
escamote ce débat parce qu'on dit bon
c'est une dépense obligatoire
incompressibles moi je veux bien qu'elle
soit obligatoire est ce qu'elle est
vraiment incompressibles je pense
qu'aujourd'hui il ya un vrai
déséquilibre entre l'offre et la demande
nous on ne produit pas hauteur de la
demande qui nous est adressé à la fois
par les clients particuliers et par les
clients institutionnels
donc il faut vraiment comme l'aurait dit
et comme l'a dit le rapport rebsamen
réhabiliter l'acte de construire ce qui
nous attendons
ce qui veut dire retravailler la densité
dans la ville a donc des immeubles plus
haut des immeubles plus haut après ce
que les édiles est ce que les mères elle
accepte mais il faut je pense je pense
que c'est un vrai débat social parce que
grosso modo vous le savez aujourd'hui on
va réduire l'artificialisation des
terres donc on aura évidemment parce
qu'au fond dans notre pays la ressource
naturelle qui est l'espace est en train
de devenir plus rare et donc
effectivement dans ce dans cette
ressource naturelle qui va être de plus
en plus limitées mais il va falloir
densifier donc a pas de fatalité à la
hausse des prix continue des logements
vous l'avez dit vous-même si les la
hausse des prix continue et on va
vraiment avoir un monde à deux vitesses
où il y aura effectivement une partie de
la population qui pourra s'offrir
d un appartement en centre-ville bas
carbone et puis les autres qui auront
vraiment beaucoup plus de difficultés
donc là évidemment c'est un sujet de
société c'est l'intérêt d'ailleurs au
delà d'un sujet de réglementation c'est
vraiment au fond quelle société on veut
pour demain donc pour l'ensemble du
secteur véronique bérex est une c'est
une révolution c'est un big bang je
disais parce que en gros un jeu je passe
votre contrôle mais béton briques acier
tous et à terme est condamné moi je
pense que j'ai un peu fort là je pense
que vous y allez un peu fort moi je
pense oui je pense que de plus en plus
en fait on se dit qu'il faut être
efficace il ya des mélange bois et béton
bas carbone qui sont vraiment optimaux
donc oui effectivement il y aura de plus
en plus de matériaux
biosourcés mais je pense que ça ne signe
pas de pardon de source source s est
effectivement des des matériaux qui sont
expliquées qu'il garde le carbone comme
le comme le bois en particulier donc
voix mélangé avec d'autres matériaux par
exemple il faut vraiment être optimale
et je pense que on continue à chercher
effectivement la brique crue je pense
qu'il va y avoir un vrai enjeu sur le
réemploi aussi qu'on ne fait que
commencer à traiter vous parliez des
bâtiments sans clim ni chauffage c'est
ou en français à sait pas encore si ça
sera bientôt à lyon d'accord quels sont
les autres projets sinon nexity qu'un
texte ces paramètres environnementaux et
durable on a effectivement la porte de
montreuil j'en ai dit un mot tout à
l'heure le village des athlètes qui là
est un must pour les jo dans le cas des
jo qui va vraiment être un mélange bois
et puis béton bas carbone et puis qui a
cette particularité très intéressante je
pense qu'il sera de plus en plus
présentes dans la ville de demain que
c'est réversible on va accueillir des
athlètes voilà on aura et quand les
athlètes seront devant transformer ces
bâtiments ou font en appartement de
taille diverse en bureau en crèche les
bâtiments réversible quoi oui mais qui
se pense en amont encore une fois ça se
passait avant ça je pense
qu'effectivement il faut pas en peur de
montreuil sur certains immeubles on a
vraiment demandé aux architectes de nous
présenter une architecture des plans en
logements et des plans en bureau et au
fond on est capable d'aller de l'un à
l'autre et on a même garanti un coût de
transformation des logements en bureau
sis ou des bureaux en logements si le
destin venait à changer pour démontrer
donc c'est vraiment des choses qui sont
de plus en plus dans nos dans nos modes
de fonctionnement et puis on a aussi je
pense une vraie incitations dès
aujourd'hui à travailler d'abord sur la
réhabilitation ça je pense que c'est
aussi une très grande transformation
être quatre cinq ans on avait quand même
le réflexe de dire bon finalement on va
construire un truc complètement neuve
qui correspond complètement à ce qu'on
veut aujourd'hui dans nos équipes il ya
vraiment le premier moment de se dire
mais qu'est ce qu'on peut faire avec ce
qui est déjà là et ça aussi c'est une
rupture est une vraie révolution d'un
homme de fonctionnement donc on peut
rêver en tout cas un logement des
bâtiments des immeubles des appartements
plus vert sans être plus cher j'insiste
elle part elle s'est peut-être préfère
apparaît aussi comme avec les voitures
électriques qui aujourd'hui sont plus
chers que les voitures thermiques mais
qui à terme nous dit on quatre ans cinq
ans d'humala le dater seront au même
prix mais les voitures électriques sauf
erreur de ma part est passée par là mais
bon ça à peu près 50% de plus et ces
deux technologies très très différente
moi c'est ça que j'ai compris dans le
logement je pense qu'on va être en
capacité de revoir nos modes
constructifs il faut les alléger il faut
les simplifier c'est en les allégeant
les simplifiant en industrialisant qu'on
finira par rendre le logement abordable
mais ça je pense qu' il n'y a pas
d'échappatoire il faut vraiment que le
logement vert soit un logement abordable
vous remercie beaucoup tous cas merci
d'arrêter avec nous véronique b d'agde
directrice général de nexity merci à
vous merci et pour construire plus vert
et plus durable certains matériaux la
dix ans la côte à l'image du bois manuel
être une maison écolo utilise des
matériaux naturels non polluants et
recyclables tels que le bois ou la
paille et se caractérise par une très
faible consommation d'énergie en 2020
treize mille maisons en bois ont vu le
jour légèreté rapidité de construction
qualités d'isolation résistance au feu
le bois possède de nombreux atouts et a
le vent en poupe mais aujourd'hui ces
constructions ne représentent que 7% du
marché de la maison individuelle
trop peu pour avoir un impact fort sur
la planète alors la commission
européenne impose qu'en 2030 toutes les
constructions neuves soient neutres en
émissions de gaz à effet de serre il
faut donc agir vite et les initiatives
se multiplient les organisateurs des
jeux olympiques de 2024 construiront en
seine saint denis le village des
athlètes en grande partie en bois et le
bois séquestrent le carbone c'est à dire
que le bois utilise carbone pour sa
croissance et quand il a avalé le
carbone l'arbre le garde dans sa matière
et il rejette d'oxygène donc c'est une
merveille il ya deux ans jean paul
viguier bâti la plus haute tour en bois
en france à bordeaux elle mesure 50
mètres de haut comprend 17 niveaux et 98
logements un coup de griffe dans le
monde de la construction mais pour y
parvenir l'architecte a dû finalement
faire des compromis
nous sommes au bord de la garonne donc à
un mètre de profondeur il ya de l'eau et
le bois ne peut pas être mis dans l'eau
et dans l'air en même temps donc il
fallait protéger le bois de ce contact
avec l'eau pour protéger le bois jean
paul viguier a dû bâtir un socle en
béton et plaçait la structure en bois
dessus un compromis qu'il a dû répéter
une seconde fois pour que le projet soit
réalisable
de la même manière nous avons découvert
que à la région de bordeaux était
soumise à des contraintes sur de
protection sur les tremblements de terre
et qui atteignait 6 6 2 sur l'échelle de
richter sont que nous avons construit un
tube qui monte sur 50 mètres de hauteur
qui contient les escaliers et des
ascenseurs en l'occurrence et qui permet
donc au plancher et aux voiles de la
tour de se stabiliser et d'être con tre
vente et au final 60 % de la surface de
la tour est en bois une vitrine du
savoir faire français et un message fort
pour l'environnement mais depuis la
crise sanitaire ce matériau est
confronté à une véritable pénurie et son
prix explosent en deux ans le bois a
augmenté de 30 à 110 % alors les
entreprises de btp tente de trouver
d'autres solutions que le bois pour
construire écolo
le mot clé pour justement répondre à
l'ampleur du défi 7,7 baisse dans les 15
ans qui viennent de l'impact carbone des
bâtiments le mot clé c'est l'innovation
et la terre crue c'est l'une des
innovations tout à fait possible surtout
dans un contexte par exemple du grand
paris où il ya des mouvements de terre
important la création de lignes et
stations de métro supplémentaires génère
40 5 millions de tonnes de terre un thé
chez encombrants qui en réalité
pourraient devenir une ressource
considérable si on l'a transformé en
briques de terre crue remettre au goût
du jour cette méthode ancestrale c'est
le défi un peu fou que s'est lancé cycle
terre
[Musique]
les terres que l'on voit ici sont des
terres qui viennent des chantiers
d'ile-de-france des chantiers du btp la
construction alors on les accueille ici
pendant un à six mois selon le degré
d'humidité kia et quand elles sont
sèches on va pouvoir passer à la
deuxième étape qu'est le broyage pour
parvenir à ces briques en terre crue les
morceaux de roche sont extraits puis la
terre est broyé grâce à cette machine en
petits grains
une fois que le broyage a eu lieu on va
mettre soi en beat by soit en vrac des
façon à pouvoir ensuite les transporter
la terre est acheminée à quelques
kilomètres dont l' usine de cycles terre
à sevran mais avant d'être transformé en
briques elle passe une batterie de tests
elle ne doit pas être pollué et doit
respecter des normes bien strictes c'est
pas un matériau qui est nouveau
toutefois il faut que aujourd'hui ils
puissent s'adapter de l' architecture
contemporaine la terre est moulé en
forme de blocs grâce à cette presse puis
placés sur une palette grâce à ce robot
au final cette brique n'aura nécessité
que de la terre et une quantité très
faible dos un matériau qui apportent un
air sain qui restitue un air frais en
été et la chaleur en hiver
si tu le perds a pour objectif de
produire 600 milles bloc par an et je
pense qu'il devrait être atteint en 2023
douar 2024 au plus tard la terre crue a
tout à fait sa place pour en remplacer
quelques mètres cube de béton dans nos
bâtiments grâce à l'utilisation de ces
matériaux écolos certains géants du
secteur ont revu leur copie et propose
notamment du béton bas carbone qui
réduit de 50 % les émissions à effet de
serre
on l'a vu le secteur de la construction
est en train de faire sa mue bonjour
amis line j'en ai dit alors on vient de
le voir les innovations ne manquent pas
et l'impression 3d et ben en fait partie
et où il a fait ressortir sa maison de
terre via une imprimante ça paraît fou
mais c'est possible plusieurs pays sont
soumis dubaï par exemple qui s'est fixé
pour objectif de réaliser 25% de ses
bâtiments avec cette technologie d'ici
trois ans en france est en train
d'arriver doucement on se souvient
notamment en 2018 de ces logements
sociaux
sorti de terre dont vient l'impression
3d dans la région de nantes on va
rappeler les avantages de l'impression
3d alors d'abord ça permet de réduire
les délais de construction et donc les
coûts ça permet également de réduire la
pénibilité sur les chantiers enfin c'est
tout bénef pour l'environnement puisque
on peut plus facilement ajuster à la
quantité de matériaux dont on a besoin
donc l'impression 3d manifestement elle
a tout bon c'est ce qui a motivé le
collectif emprunte à se lancer
exactement ça se passe dans la région
d'angers la société e r b a réuni autour
d'elle une vingtaine d'entreprises 1
pour monter donc ce collectif notamment
la société bâti print 3d qui était à
l'origine de ces logements à nantes
ensemble ils ont sorti de terre une
première maison de 130 m² avec cinq
pièces sur deux niveaux et ce qui est
fou c'est cadny gruny parpaings juste un
robot qui est commandée par un
ordinateur qui est à la manoeuvre
exactement alors ce robot poli articulé
vous le voyez il dépose des couches
successives de mousse une mousse ultra
légères qui s'exposent de 40 fois son
volume qui durcit en quelques secondes
avant de servir de coffrage pour couler
du béton les murs sont donc montés
strate par strate en un temps record au
final ça nous donne une maison mieux
isoler et aussi solide qui maisons en
briques donc l'innovation de ce projet
tient on l'a compris m il ya
l'impression 3 2 mais pas seulement mais
ici on est vraiment dans l'économie 100%
circulaire il faut savoir que tous les
matériaux désir sont récupérées alors la
mousse par exemple figurez vous qu'elle
est fabriquée à partir de bouteilles en
plastique recyclées grosso modo pour
construire une maison il faut les treize
mille bouteilles en moyenne le béton lui
il bénéficie d'une technologie assez
bluffante qui nous vient de la société
neo lietaer neolys transforme les
déchets de chantier non recyclables en
granulats réutilisable à l'infini vous
avez également la société terra nova qui
valorise des terres extrêmes de terrain
agricole voisin ou encore la peinture
qui elle aussi est recyclé à partir de
vieux pots qui nous viennent de la
société cire couleur donc on est
vraiment humiliée dans une nouvelle
approche de la construction d'ailleurs
ça se voit au niveau de l'architecturé
des différentes saisons oui alors c'est
vrai que grâce à l'impression 3d ses
formes sont plus douces plus arrondies
elles sont plus faciles à intégrer dans
un environnement naturel à
l'environnement qui je le précise et
autonomes parce que le jardin utilise la
technique de la permaculture et il est
alimenté par l'eau de pluie qui est
directement récupérés du toit et puis
d'un dernier mot le projet bénéficie
david un autre outil innovant au delà la
3d c'est la réalité augmentée ça va être
très utile au moment de la conception
pourrait bien se rendre compte de
l'emprise ou des volumes de sa future
maison bon emilie votre maison elle me
plait combien ça coûte de faire
construire comme ça sa maison en 3d et
puis parce que tout ça sera
commercialisée par ci un petit peu tôt
pour le dire pour l'instant si cette
maison c'est une sorte de démonstrateurs
on attend le retour d'expérience pour
évaluer la performance environnementale
effective de cette maison et puis son
coup bien sûr alors la société verbe est
formelle elle ne veut pas d'une
construction et dit east elle nous dit
finalement l'idée c'est de compenser
tous ces surcoûts environnementaux par
le réemploi des matériaux et puis
évidemment les circuits courts avec
toujours ce même leitmotiv montrer
qu'une autre manière de construire est
possible et c'est ce qu'on a cherché à
montrer dans cette émission merci emilie
elle est pourvu que ça dure les missions
qui rend les co-responsables c'est fini
pour aujourd'hui magazine avoir au
revoir et notamment replay sur
publicsenat.fr rendez-vous dans quinze
jours
[Musique]